can you picture Russell Crowe as
Wolverine it's hard to imagine anyone
other than Hugh Jackman but Russell is
actually good friends with Brian Singer
who asked him to take on the part first
Russell however had just finished
filming Gladiator where his character's
companion was a wolf and he didn't want
to be seen as Wolfie like Mr Wolf all of
Russell's wolf related scenes were cut
from the final version of gladiator
anyway so he didn't need to worry still
apparently Russell got to see some
concept art of Wolverine they showed me
art and stuff like that and it's like it
doesn't look like me and that gave
Russell an idea I'll tell you who it
looks like as it looks like you Jackman
sometimes recommendations go a long way
towards making Marvel history